hey everyone i'm karthik krishna and
this is a video abstract for our paper
now on archive title finite horizon
energy optimal trajectories and unsteady
flows
this is joint work with professor steve
brunton and jian song
so in this work we bring together ideas
from model predictive control lagrangian
coherent structure theory to understand
plaque planning in the ocean
than the atmosphere and as such so if
you're interested in any of these ideas
this paper might be really useful for
you
all right so what we're interested in is
we're interested in autonomous vehicles
particularly we noticed that a lot of
the autonomous vehicles
or mobile sensors that you want to
deploy in the ocean
uh wait sorry a lot of the autonomous
vehicles that you want to deploy
for the applications for ecosystem
monitoring transportation and climate
monitoring
they all operate in fluid flows so
unsteady flow fields like the ocean
or the atmosphere and what's particular
about the ocean and atmosphere is a lot
of time they generate massive current so
you can see
the nazi big waves this huge current
that's hitting this boat right now
and a lot of the mobile sensors that we
have are kind of like the
robot here that's using its buoyancy to
move up and down but it's not
able to produce a lot of actuation so if
this current
is uh this robots within this current
it's not going to be produ
able to produce a lot of actuation to
move around so you're going to be
dominated by the forces of the current
mostly
so what we really want to understand in
the interest of saving energy
is how do you perform movement using
limited actuation
so and how does that relate to the
dynamics of the background flow field so
given a certain flow field
what kind of trajectories can you
produce to move around in it and that's
where the idea of low energy transport
comes in
so let me try to make this clearer
so you can imagine a flow field so this
is what's known as the double gyre flow
field
and the white dot that's moving around
in it you can think of as one of the
agents or robots you want to drop in the
ocean for mobile sensing
and right now it's not using any of its
actuation so the dynamics of this is
given by
this complex looking equation that
basically is just saying
the velocity of the robot is the same as
the arrow mark that it's standing on
and plus whatever velocity that it
produces by its own propulsion but right
now it's not doing any of that
now if you wanna what you wanna do is
you wanna
move to the green cross here and you
want to think okay how do i
use my use there to move around and
really generally have two strategies for
this
strategy number one is you just shoot
straight
all cylinders towards your goal and this
is really expensive because
a lot of time the current is going to be
opposing you or not even with the
direction so you're supposed to not only
move towards it but you need to overcome
the current that's dragging you back
the other idea is to use small course
corrections so this uh
small used that dot's using to
to basically move in the right place in
the right time so the ocean flow field
is going to carry to you where you want
to be
so and that's the idea of leveraging
flow structures and that's really the
kind of trajectories that we want to
start looking into
for movement all right so this is really
important
so given that we want to look at
leveraging flow structures
we need an algorithm or we need a way to
visualize these flow structures so
one really cool way that's from
dynamical system theory
is this idea of lagrangian coherence
structures so these are the lagrangian
coherent structures for the double gyro
flow field that i just showed a slide
back
and you see these red and blue curves
and what they basically are telling you
is if i
dropped a bunch of uh drifters like you
can see
in this video here when it loops back
that
where are these drifters going to move
towards so they the
the red curves are what are called as
attracting lcs so your drifters are
going to move towards them
and the blue curves are what's known as
repelling lcs so that's where the
drifters are going to move apart from
and they're computed using this side
algorithm called
uh lagran um sorry the finite time
lyapunov exponent
and the finite time the open of exponent
calculation involves a finite time
uh forward integration or a backward
integration depending on the time your
curve you're trying to compute and
really what you're asking with this
computation
is how are nearby trajectories being
pulled apart
in forward or backward time and that
gives you these curves
all right and also particularly
lagrangian current structures has been
related to
energy optimal trajectories in the past
so uh
this review is not really exhaustive so
we just picked out two which stood out
to us
if there are any other works that you're
familiar with we'd definitely like to
hear from you
so the first paper that came out was in
2005
by inang shaddan and marsden and what
they showed was that if you took a
boundary value problem in the ocean and
you want to
construct a trajectory between two
points those trajectories tend to have
overlapped with lagrangian core and
structures
and three years later this other video
is basically showing this other idea is
what
um if you want a energy optimal
trajectory why don't
you just like follow the lagrangian code
and structure so use a line path line
following algorithm and just stay on the
lagrangian current structure
and what you find that is the energy
that you spend while moving in
these lagrangian coding structures are
much lesser so lesser actuation
all right so we're going to come back to
lagrangian coherent structures in in
a few it will be a while so before that
we want to understand
uh we want to get our own algorithm for
generating trajectories so for that we
turn to model predictive control
so model predictive control is basically
two steps step one is you optimize over
a finite
horizon finite time horizon so this
dashed line is this
forward prediction of how your flow
field is going to look like
and you optimize over it and what you do
in the next step is you just take the
first step of that
and then you go back and then you
generate a new trajectory so in video
that
winds up looking like this now i've
color coded these dashed lines by what
the
control effort at every instant is so
whenever it starts glowing yellow that
means at that instant
that first step is spending a lot of
energy
so the cost function so i did talk about
optimization so there's a cost function
here
so the cost function that we're using
has two terms the first term is the
distance from the goal
and the second term is the control
effort so the
energy is spent and the distance from
the goal and these two are fighting
against each other basically
you if you minimize one the other one is
going to grow which i'll explain in a
bit
so there's particular advantages to
using this method so a lot of times
uh when we're using mobile sensors in
the ocean the flow field isn't really
well dissolved so you really don't have
a super accurate model of how your
sensor is going to be moving around
so this because we are reoptimizing
every instant
we're quite robust to some kind of
uncertainty like that so if you got the
flow field wrong
you're going to recalculate anyway and
you're going to look further ahead each
step because you moved a bit
so you're really taking in create
generating more information so
that's really an advantage second
advantage is you can
since this is an optimization a
numerical optimization you can start
coding in limits of your actuation so if
your
mobile sensor can't generate more than a
speed of five kilometers per hour you
can code that kind of thing in
so the mall predictive control has two
parameters so we want to start messing
around with these parameters to
understand what are the range of
trajectories you can generate in the
ocean
and we generally have two parameters so
the first we can lump in these two
purple parameters which i'm going to
show in second
and the other one is this blue parameter
called the time horizon
so this is the time horizon and the
other one is what we call the r by q
ratio
now the r by q ratio is this ratio of
of the penalties of energy to control
effort
sorry the state error to control effort
so
you can think of really simple ways you
can think of a small rbiq
is for when you're planning a trajectory
with a for a vehicle class that's like a
speedboat that can produce massive
actuation
and you don't have you have to be very
precise on where you want to be so if
you want to dock
at a harbor or something you have to be
exactly there at that point
and the other when you think about large
rbiq you want to think about
the thing that i showed in the first
slide where it's just moving in buoyancy
and can't produce massive actuation so
it's
going to be carried so you want to start
using well basically we're interested in
really large roq
actually okay
so in this slide what i'm showing is
what happens when you start sweeping
through so i'm like
going through all the ryq's and i'm
showing how this trajectory is changing
and so what's really good is a lot of
the orbits that we get
are these closed loitering states around
where you can just keep hovering around
in a low energy fashion around your
cross mark
and what we notice is the orbits get
larger and larger as the energy penalty
drops because it can't
accurately use more energy to stay
around the x mark
but also what we realize is the
qualitative shape of these orbits are
changing around so
if you looked at r by q equals 20 and
then just moved a little bit further in
r by q equals 26
what happens is this i shape turns into
this huge
shape that traces out the gyrus shape
so that's really interesting so that you
can think of as like this kind of
trajectory bifurcation
so when you think what's happening is
this rbi q20 trajectory is growing and
growing and growing and it suddenly
becomes unstable
and then it switches over to this new
kind of trajectory so
in our work with you know the time
horizon equals four
we found an entire zoo of these kind of
trajectories that
start going and you can think of each of
these qualitative trajectories
as a trajectory for a different vehicle
class so you can think of
for the speed board to a ship to a small
agent like you can go through the entire
spectrum of all kinds of vehicles and
then you get a different
kind of trajectory for each time when
you're planning
okay so next we bring back
lcs so what we see here is this video
of the drifter moving around along the
double jar with the lcs product in the
background
but now we have the model predictive
control working and what's different
really with moderative control now
from the past work that's been done is
the moderate control generates an entire
family of trajectories
so at every instant you're generating an
entirely new trajectory so
you can start visualizing okay like how
is
each trajectory uh changing with the
lagrangian coherent structure in the
background
so a lot of what you see in this video
is there's a lot of overlapping between
the forecast of the mpc
and with the lcs so i'll play it back
and you can also see that the sensor
start mobile sensor of the dot starts
moving around
with the lcs which is really interesting
especially because this lcs
is computed with a time horizon of 15 or
something
such but the else the mpc time horizon
is just merely four and it's still able
to like
um it's still able to look at all these
structures and move with them for some
reason
what we also find is that when you're
moving across the middle
blue lcs here we start spending a lot of
energy so you can see that when the
the forward horizon starts turning
really yellow really bright yellow that
means spending a lot of energy then
now the middle lcs is particularly
interesting because what it's called is
a hyperbolic lcs so a hyperbolic lcs is
this curve where if passive drifters
with no control
are going to be repelled normally away
from it the other kind is the ones in
the corner here so
sorry you can think of the ones in
this area here the lcs in that area are
shear driven so they're they're not
driven by normal movement away so
there's something really interesting
about this phenomena
okay so now what we do is we are going
to look at two cases so
r by q equals 4 and r by q equals 100
and we're going to
see what changes with the lcs
all right so what you notice like what's
expected is we're not using the lcs at
all at the start of an r by q equals 4
trajectory whereas
the rbc 100 trajectory is still moving
around with the lcs
but what happens when you get really
close to the goal is
you start moving around with the lcs so
you can see that it's moving
right with the intersection here and
that's really interesting
because so what's happening what's
possibly happening is that the state
error is growing really small as you get
close
so then your u preservation term starts
kicking in and you start being
very energy efficient near the goal but
far away you're just shooting straight
towards it like a speedboat
all right so the other parameter that we
can talk about is the time horizon so
the time horizon is basically
uh how far you can look ahead with your
model predictive control
now
the time horizon if it's really long
means that you have a lot of information
about your flow field so practically
speaking
if you have a if you're very sure
about the flow field at long scales away
from you you want to have a high time
horizon
but normally we won't be able to do this
because our sensors are small
and we're not able to track a large
large area so we only have very local
information so
essential ideally we want to be able to
work even with short time horizons
but we can see the difference of our
trajectories vary with the time horizon
so
in this video what you can see is the
one on the
when you start using more information
you can get to the goal quicker
both trajectories are using the red lcs
because both of them
are moving with an r by q equals hundred
but the one on the right
is uh using the red lcs to move towards
the right
and then loop around a bit and then go
to left whereas this trajectory is going
straight
and it's able to use that bit of
information that it has to move straight
to this goal
and that's really interesting but now
what we want to do is we want to look at
if we sweep through all the time
horizons and all the ryq's
what are the best trajectories we can
produce and how do we look at that
so for that we have this plot
so on this plot what we're doing is on
the y-axis we're plotting
uh the energy spent across the entire
trajectory
and on the x-axis we're plotting what
the state error is along the entire
trajectory
and we get these nice pareto optimal
curves going around here
and what we see is the one the region
around one
is where we're using massive energy to
get to where we want to go
and in the region around two is where we
have this
optimal movement that we have to get
towards the goal but in a really energy
optimal way
and beyond that you get really bad
trajectories and these trajectories
even if they are technically using
lesser energy than
two the the trade-off in uh
uh the state error is way too high at
them so we're really interested in
these uh trajectories around two
also what uh thing we notice is that a
lot of the
uh time where i a lot of the time
horizons that are even really short
really do well so like
a time horizon of two to four is
actually doing pretty pretty well
comparably
and we also see a bit of convergence
towards red as you
increase uh i'm i might have missed this
to start so
the time for right the colors are the
time horizon and what we're doing is
we're sweeping through r by q so
uh really low r by q to high r by q
and it's tracing that curve like that
but we were also interested in one more
thing
so this is for a double girder frequency
of 2 pi by 10 that means it's
the gyre is moving back and forth at
this frequency
but alternatively we can also try a
bunch of other frequencies and this was
really motivated by
studies and mixing of inertial particles
so what you find with inertial particles
is when you
drop inertial particles in a double gel
and you vary the frequency it has this
high pass and low pass filtering effect
and you get you get some of that here
too interestingly so
as at a really low low frequency
we get this nice quick period optimal
curve but as i keep increasing the
frequency
you start increasing the time period
that's changing frequency and as we keep
changing that basically
we get these curves and this curve
starts to break apart kind of like this
resonance phenomena
and it goes back to actually being
normal and this is really interesting
i think it warrants further discussion
or further
what you say research into this area
okay so that brings me to the end of the
talk really um
here's the conclusions is we have
we found strong connections between the
gyrodynamics and optimal trajectories
and you know overlapping family of mpc
horizons and
the frequency dependence between gyro so
what more you can find in the paper are
you can find
what reject more trajectories look like
there's a comprehensive
list of figures which show different
trajectories when the frequency is high
the frequency is low the time horizon is
changing
we also have a discussion about how
timing in the gyre
is really important so uh different time
horizons will perform even for a little
increase in time horizon you can get
suddenly drastically good performance
and there's a histogram comparing the
energy spent or trajectories to what
how much energy or how much flow
velocity is in the background flow
but there's one more thing future work
so
with future work we're really interested
in so what we looked in this paper is
how one agent moves towards the
goal state essentially right but we can
also do one more thing where we can have
an
entire fleet of mobile sensors that are
all trying to move towards the goal
and this gives us a few ideas so we can
think about multi-agent coordination
where we're trying to get them all close
to each other or far away from each
other really quickly
or we can even understand how
uh the so when you have mpc acting
with the double jar it becomes this
entirely new dynamical system and we can
think of
oh what are the attracting regions in
this new dynamical system and how is
how do we quantify that and how do we
quantify control flow fields
and third we want to understand okay so
we
observed a lot of phenomena in
throughout this paper
and we want to understand okay
theoretically what is
producing all this why do mpc and fdle
have this connection
and so that's that's another direction
so thank you for listening to this talk
you can find the work on archive you can
you can play around with the code on
github